what up guys welcome to Pearl daily
where I cover this week's treachery
debauchery and craziness before I start
don't forget like the video and get
yourself a women shouldn't vote t-shirt
so today I'm going to be talking about
this trend in society that I have seen
so as you guys know women love spending
men's money yes that is really what we
do best we love to just swipe swipe
swipe our credit cards we just like to
swipe swipe swipe but we don't like to
take responsibility over the debt so you
constantly see women fighting for rights
to spend men's money and this trend has
ruined movies in my opinion now movies
in the early 2000s were just a little
bit different a little bit better in my
opinion for example and when you would
go to a theater you knew that the
actress in the movie was the most
attractive chick really around like it
was Megan Fox back in the day you used
to have Margo Robbie in her prime but as
you see the movie companies catering to
a female audience what you start to see
is the women getting less and less
attractive I pointed out this phenomenon
where I noticed all of the actresses
like of today just really were not as
beautiful as the actresses of the past
now guys when I go to a movie I want to
feel a little bad about myself I don't
want to see no average chicks on TV the
same thing with the guys but really they
just keep selling us dream like I
watched this Grace Anatomy I reacted to
this graay Anatomy clip it was like a
girl that was a sick having two doctors
fight over her in what world these are
tall Handsome Jack doctors I'm like
they're just going to move on anyway now
a movie that was actually awesome back
in the early 2000s I remember growing up
was Mean Girls now Lindsay Lohan in her
prime was absolutely beautiful but in
this new reboot they have decided to
make it woke and use mid chicks why are
they doing this to us Mary Morgan says
they're rebooting Mean Girls 2004 a
cinematic m Masterpiece and are ruining
everything we loved about
it oh hell
no move hey PG-13
please what's that Lord is the queen bee
Regina George don't look her in the ey
you could be really hot if we change
like welcome to Health and Human
Sexuality we will be getting into
abstinence of course Then followed by in
the spring condoms and choking you're
learning things now that I don't know
how to
teach are you okay in there we're
concerning either doing drugs or having
a toilet baby
ew we as women have to be able to
support each other get in loser welcome
Katie you're never going to believe what
I found this morning your burn book mom
go make snacks for sure for sure sure
Regina
yeah do you like gum sure we will help
you
caddy why are you dress so scary it's
Halloween Katie if you don't dress
that is shaming us that's
just
unprofessional what what's
this we're going to make her
pay all we've done is make Regina hotter
and revive the wet
look
K push her Regina really should be
lifting through her
[Music]
glutes incorrect you have to pick a
French name Chanel no
sh no
beon
so as you could see they replaced all of
the chick which used to be eights to T
with a bunch of mids why
why okay so Mary points out it's set in
modern day they make tick talks got to
appeal to that gen Z audience and name
check shaming so you see how in
these commercials they like subtly put
the wokeness in they subtly make
everybody uglier why I might want to go
and watch a movie with Zack Efron and
Vanessa hudgin two extremely beautiful
people obviously they're way hotter than
anybody I know all right obviously but
it's like it's supposed to be like that
it's TV they made caddy Heron originally
Lindsay Lohan mid even though the
Catalyst of her entire character Arc is
not realizing she's hot Janice is race
swapped and they made her fat Damian is
also race race swapped because why not
Karen also got race swapped new Regina
George just dropped except she's mid and
fat now also WTF is this yes and that's
what I've noticed the more they appeal
to a female audience the more the movies
just start to suck they start to get
more woke they start to get less
attractive everybody becomes mid when I
thought that was like the prerequisite
to be an actress like Angelina Jolie
Jennifer Aniston you know growing up I
always knew now now I know this is not a
this is not a poor Pearl thing but like
I always knew like I was never going to
model nobody was gonna Mo nobody that I
knew was going to model because you had
to be exceptional but now it's like
everyone can be a model everyone can be
a top actress and we wonder why these
movies are tanking just like these
superhero movies when they put these
chick as lead Superman why why obvious
it's like a five five blonde chick that
never been in the gym in her life trying
to fight what like we don't we don't
believe this stuff and commenters are
seeing this they're sick of the wokeness
being shoved down their throat so the
top comment is Naomi says replacing
Lindsay Lohan is the eighth deadly sin
fresh fit Chef few they're all fat as
well PS ruining everything is the left's
ideology and yeah that's what we keep
seeing we keep seeing all of these
movies and I haven't seen it maybe it's
amazing I don't know but I am sure that
LE ism is just going to be shoved down
our throat why do movies need to be
political why can't they just be funny
movies why can't we go and just watch a
funny movie and be done with it so the
next story that I'm going to cover is
actually the saddest story um that I
have read in a really long time there is
an innocent baby girl that has been
condemned to death by British judges
let's take a look the father of Indie
Gregory this poor child who is uh facing
death because the British government is
attempting to kill the child even
contrary to what the government of Italy
and what the Vatican are offering which
is citizenship and treatment at the
hospital benino Jesu uh we have him on
the line he's not in court right now
this should be an international Scandal
but because we've heard this story now
every six months at least every year
specifically out of the United Kingdom
we've become callous to it and the story
is that a baby faces medical problems
and the parents of the baby want to to
treat the baby and want to help the baby
and want to keep the baby alive and the
Psychopaths running the UK government
and health system more broadly who run
the health systems in the west want to
kill the child because they now view
death as treatment Mr Gregory thank you
for coming on the show thank you thank
you for so sorry about everything you're
going through it's horrific the the
health problems of your child are
obviously horrific in themselves I pray
to God I never have to go through
anything like that I it's it's the
greatest fear any parent has and then on
top of that your government will not
permit you to treat your child or keep
your child alive and on top of that the
UK government will not allow the
government of Italy which gave your
child citizenship will not allow the
pope will not allow the Vicor of Christ
on Earth to help treat your child they
simply want to kill your baby yeah tell
us what's what's happening we're just
absolutely disgusted um I'm embarrassed
to be British at the minute you've got
another country offering to pay for the
treatment and they're blocking her from
going to Italy they're blocking her to
for coming home to have exibition
they're just being it's just so cruel
and INE I just don't understand where
does the case stand now I know I I
really appreciate you're making time I
know you've got a lot of other things on
your mind I I know that there was a
chance you were going to be in court
this morning or this afternoon by by
your time so where where does it all
stand there's a court hearing going off
now it's online virtual I've just had to
pop out to get my daughter from school
and then go back to the hospital and
then join again but yeah the the appeal
is this appeal is to do with where Indie
they're trying to block Indie from
coming home they're trying to say she
can only go to a hospice or the hospital
to have a treatment withdrawn so they've
blocked us from going Italy and now
they're trying to block us from taking
it home it's just cruel is there any is
there any hope at this point that you
will be able to bring your baby to Italy
for treatment at the Bambino Jesu
hospital or is that completely off the
table I know the Italians are doing as
much as they can in the background and
we're just hoping that something will
come of it like at any point it's it's
for the UK government and the Italian
government to come to some sort of agree
that's what we're hoping for now short
of that you you'd like to take your
daughter home of course you know you
don't want to ship your daughter off to
a hospice to to just be neglected
officially neglected by the UK medical
system so what is their argument why
won't they allow you to take your own
daughter home if if you know things are
going to go south as I suppose they will
for all of us eventually but if you know
if this is really her time but why why
won't they let her have her her final
moments in her home with her family who
who love her rather than in some
clinical U UK institution it was it was
in the original court order that she
could we could choose for her to come
home I think when they found out about
Italy I think they got scared and are
trying to block us from taking home
because they're probably scared that
we're going to jump on a on a plane or
something and go go over there that's
what it feels like of course I actually
I should have realized that I because I
couldn't figure out I said it just seems
so needlessly cruel to say you can't
even take your own daughter home if she
is going to die you're not you can't but
right because they don't want you to
flee to flee to go get medical treatment
from Italy and the and the pope from
from the Vatican though now your
daughter is officially an Italian
citizen do I have that right yeah that's
right yeah exactly as a parent in the UK
you've got when you go to the courts
you've got no rights you've set up to
fail everybody's against you my
daughter's not brain dead she's moving
she's breathing she's she's alert there
children in America with the same
disease who's nine I've been talking to
the parents of them it's just it's all
down to money it's all to cost and
resources in the UK so that that's what
this is it's it's not that you know your
your daughter would would just die
immediately or anything like that it's
not what they're saying which is that oh
she's in this horrific kind of pain and
it's whatever euthanasia quote unquote
arguments that they make it's it's
rather that this is It's a socialist
healthc care system they've got a finite
amount of money and they just they just
don't want to spend the money to keep
your daughter alive I don't think she's
worth the cost cuz she's potentially got
a shorter life but nobody knows when
they're going to pass way so they're not
God they shouldn't play this they
shouldn't play God this I I I first
covered the story on the show yesterday
and and the the thing that makes me it's
not the thing that makes me angriest is
what they're doing to your daughter the
thing that makes me second angriest is
that I see what they think I see what
the judge is thinking I see what the UK
government is thinking I see their logic
the problem is their premises are wrong
and the premises are wrong for exactly
the reason you just said because they're
saying well look she's going to die
eventually yeah you're going to die
eventually too I'm going to die
eventually too you don't know when
you're going to die you maybe you'll die
in 50 years maybe you'll go get hit by a
bus tomorrow does that mean that we're
going to stop feeding you today does
that mean that we're going to stop
giving you basic medical care it's just
so it's just a culture of death that is
so shocking that when it happened the
first couple of times it was an
international Scandal now the biggest
Scandal is that it's not an
international Scandal that not nearly
enough people are talking about this
egregious Injustice that your government
a supposedly civilized government is
doing to you and your family and your
daughter I know it's disgraceful it's
like everyone in the UK is just not
aware of what's happening around him and
you you've got another country Italy who
are doing everything they can and India
wasn't even Italian she's got Italian C
citizenship now but that country is
doing everything they can to help so why
can't my country help why can't they
come to some sort of agreements why
can't my country help why can't my
country help my own daughter can you
imagine that that is that is such that
phrase is such an indictment of what has
happened to the the medical system and
the whole political order in these
countries uh I I know that you're uh
extremely busy Mr Gregory so I'm going
to let you go and I know that there you
know sometimes we say if if there's a a
real uh important International cause we
say well how can we help where can we
donate I know that what we're talking
about here is a matter of hours or days
that the kind of urgency so of course I
encourage everyone to uh pray for you
and your family and for your daughter
that there is a a happy conclusion you
know e even as unlikely as that seems
right now a priest friend of mine a
British priest friend of mine pointed
out once that prayer is not the last
resort prayer is the first Resort and so
we will all absolutely be praying for
you um if there's if there's any other
way that we can help uh you know please
do please do let us know right thank you
cheers thank thank you Mr Gregory man
what a great clip that was now hey hey
hey ring that Bell subscribe to the
Michael nolles YouTube channel when I
first saw this story I couldn't even
believe it was real um I I saw the clip
of his baby just playing on my timeline
on Twitter the baby just like his
daughter looks so happy and she wasn't
she didn't look sick she looked like
full of life and I couldn't believe that
they wouldn't bring her to the to Italy
if they were offering to pay for the
treatment um I I couldn't really see
what the problem was if another country
is coming in and offering to try to
treat them um and it kind of hits home
to my family because I have a cousin
that was supposed to die when he was 2
um and he ended up living until he was
13 and he really was a blessing to our
family in the time that he was alive and
you see this disregard for human life on
the left particularly the life of
children and The Unborn so you you guys
already know I'm pro-life but to me it's
it was just an absolute travesty that
they they wouldn't accept free treatment
I I didn't really understand the the why
and I was actually explaining the story
to a girl on my volleyball team and she
was telling me that it's actually really
common here apparently this happens all
the time where they just have a
disregard for human life and
unfortunately the the child did pass
away in the last couple of days um the
comments on this video said the UK
Judiciary is literally satanic and pro
death Vic says I think that it is a bit
more of a moral dilemma than these guys
make it out to be surely some medical
conditions make life not worth living
right is that what this is about no I
just think there's some sanctity of life
that every person has I think that comes
from God and I I think when you start to
life and not do everything you can to
keep life I I think it's satanic I think
it's immoral and even just watching
videos of the the baby it wasn't like
she was unhappy and just suffer like the
baby looked so happy she looked so happy
Ann pakur says this is pure Madness how
can the UK government assume and take
custody over your child I actually
interviewed someone on the show who had
a 13-year-old that the government took
custody of this isn't uncommon it's not
unheard of it happens all the time here
um and this is just anecdotally from
living in the UK for the past two years
in my lifetime guys some of the things
that are now legal and happen I cannot
believe are allowed you know I I think
in my lifetime I've seen an election
arguably get stolen I see fathers lose
custody of their children and now we're
seeing babies be killed by the
government be sentenced to death by the
government it's really disgusting how
far we've come as a society where we
don't value life so another Trend that
I've really seen I know people will
always say it's not real life it's
social media like these cases are Fringe
cases but it's really crazy how social
media becomes real life very quickly
I'll give you an example when I was 18 I
was playing volleyball in Ohio at the
time and I remember when the Caitlyn
Jenner award was given to Bruce Jenner
or like the woman's award was given to
Bruce Jenner you know in a couple of
years after that I ended up seeing trans
people in our dorm a couple of years
after that I saw trans people in my
volleyball tournament what started on
social media became real life really
quickly even with the the the child
passing away what started on social
media became real life quickly because
you start to hear instances that this
has happened in real life what I've
learned in my lifetime is that social
media becomes the real world quicker
than you think and another Trend that I
have seen is this trend of young boys
getting
the beat out of them just jumped I
I've seen this trend with girls too but
I've seen it especially with boys there
was a Las Vegas team that was beaten to
death by bullies for standing up for his
friend Las Vegas team Jonathan Lewis 17
is beaten to death by a huge swarm of
bullies after standing up for a smaller
friend who they just
popped Jonathan Lewis a 17-year-old boy
from Las Vegas tragically passed away
after being brutally attacked by a gang
of 15 18-year-old youth near Rancho High
School he intervened to protect a friend
who was being robbed by a group leading
to a severe beating that left him
bleeding in the head despite the effort
by doctors at University Medical Center
he succumbed to his injuries Days Later
Jonathan's father mourned his son's loss
urging forgiveness for the attackers
while emphasizing the need for teaching
youth peaceful coexistence videos
circulated on social media capturing the
vicious attack showing multiple youths
assaulting Jonathan as he laid defense
on the ground his father described him
as courageous and expressed his desire
to donate Jonathan's organs to save
others the devastated family set up a go
fundme to honor Jonathan's memory
highlighting his loving and giving
nature his passion for art and his role
as a caring older brother the incident
has promoted a homicide investigation by
the Las Vegas Metropolitan Police with
plans to charge several students
involved in the attack with murder the
family seeks to focus on Jonathan's
Legacy remembering him for his kindness
and dedication to the community so a a
17-year-old is supposed to go to school
and be protected and this is why I say
that women teachers should not be the
majority we need to bring male teachers
back into school because female teachers
cannot protect their students from this
stuff male teachers bring order to chaos
and what you see in these School
environments is similar to what you see
in single mother home where it is just
absolutely chaotic and the kids in these
schools often times are from single
mother homes anyway they go to school
and there's no structure no order and
now you have a kid that was supposed to
go to school and be safe dying because
he got jumped by a load of students and
this is the America this is the the
trend that America is starting to go to
we're we're seeing lawlessness and a lot
of these major cities and it's really
really sad to see and I think what makes
this story especially sad is that he was
standing up for his friend that was
robbed he was literally just standing up
for his friend trying to do the right
thing and he ends up getting jumped by a
bunch of people people and you wonder
why you see men not getting involved in
these types of situations anymore why
risk it when your life is on the line
and females women we don't always
anticipate this that really doing the
right thing or doing the brave thing in
a lot of these situations may result in
men losing their lives and and I think
that's one thing that women really can't
relate to as much in the existence of a
guy is men are always calculating the
violence that could come from prot ing
somebody or getting involved in
something and the sad thing is for
Jonathan Lewis doing doing the
courageous thing lost him his life you
know and this increase in violence I
have seen from both men and women in my
lifetime growing up I I really did not
see this violence every you know it was
kind of something that happened like I'm
from Chicago I lived in the suburb and
all of the violent stuff would just
happen in the city like we would know
okay there's one part of the city all
the crazy stuff happens and we're in the
suburbs we we're kind of avoiding that
but more and more I see the violence
seeping out into the suburbs and
happening in more places that I know and
also happening in more relationship you
know we've talked a lot about how I
believe that women are more violent than
men um and I saw an article recently of
a woman talking about how she used to
hit her husband let's pull it up I used
to hit my husband I felt scared and
ashamed of what I'd done I apologized
and thought it was a oneoff but it was a
p pattern that would carry us on for the
next 10 years so I wanted to read this
article a lot of times we act like
female violence is rare and not common
but through interviewing thousands of
people I actually couldn't believe how
common it was for men to be in abusive
relationships I it actually blew my mind
the amount of men that I have met that
have camera rolles on their phone
dedicated to protecting themselves from
the women they never want to be accused
of abuse so they make sure they keep
videos of what the chick is doing um I
was also shocked and surprised by the
amount of men that have told me they've
been hit by their Partners where they I
I've even had a guy say that a girl
tried to hit him with a car I've heard
women laugh about that on podcast and
there is an article by Florence Terry
talking about how she used to hit her
husband and I and I wanted to read it to
you guys to give really a little more
insight from the female point of view of
an abusive woman because it's never
talked about it's always the ab abuse of
men it is never the abuse of women
experience I used to hit my husband the
first time I struck him was during an
argument over money he decided to pay
off alone without telling me and we'd
gone overdrawn I was worried and tried
to discuss it with him at which point he
left the room I felt we hadn't talked it
through properly and followed him the
next minute I was hitting him around the
head I remember losing control of my
limbs lashing out afterwards he was
upset and I cried I felt scared and
ashamed of what I'd done I apologized
and thought it was a one-off but the the
pattern carried on for 10 years I met my
husband through mutual friends at Durham
University I was 19 and he was 5 years
older more worldly and mature he was
less serious too and made me laugh we
were married 5 years later he had a job
in it and by then I had started working
as a divorce lawyer the early days of
our marriage were steady but as the
stress of my job and responsibilities
grew I took it out on him after the
first time it happened again about 18
months later I felt a surge of Rage I
couldn't control my anger would escalate
during arguments over household chores
or my husband coming to bed late I
remember feeling I was out of my body
watching myself and telling myself to
stop but I couldn't I would hit him hard
hitting to hurt one time I picked up a
table and crashed it down so hard on the
ground I left bite marks on his arms a
couple of times it was similar to the
way siblings fight yet he never struck
back he'd hold up his hands to Shield
himself which made me feel even worse I
know my husband felt emotionally hurt at
times it was upsetting for him to think
that the person he loved wanted to hurt
him but he never threatened to leave me
he felt there was more to me than my
behavior and that we still had a strong
marriage I'm a petite woman a little
over eight stone and my husband is a big
man yet he said he didn't feel
emasculated and that I never physically
heard him while I exploded he remained
calm and I was thankful but I was also
frustrated that he wasn't communicating
fully with
me what is there to commute okay sorry
guys what is there to commute
so she's beating him and she's
frustrated that he wasn't communicating
for all right all right sorry I was
using violence to get a reaction I was
verbally aggressive too I'd make
demanding comments sarcastic and
personal attack all things that erode
love I'd blame him preach and criticize
I couldn't understand why I wanted to be
so aggressive to someone I love I lacked
self-awareness I now realized the anger
I felt was to do with my stress and low
self-esteem I was packing my life too
tightly working long hours a day as a
lawyer volunteering the citizens advice
brew and doing soup runs for the
homeless I had what I felt was a
privileged upbringing my family was
middle class and I went to private
schools I felt I had an obligation to
repay this to society I thought I should
be super human and I felt my husband
should be too to other people I seemed
calm and accommodating a kind of
Peacemaker but inside I was pent up and
deeply ashamed of myself and I wanted to
point this out too because you never
know what happens with women behind
closed doors men many women in
public are perfectly Pleasant many women
to everybody else is a nice person but
behind clothes doors you have no idea
how they treat their husband and this is
why a lot of men are afraid of marriage
because women switch up and she admitted
that she did and if she's admitting this
guys how many people has this happened
to eventually I accepted something had
to change I'd heard about domestic
violence groups but only for men I felt
my behavior carried an added stigma for
women women weren't unexpected to be
violent especially high-powered working
women who volunteered for Charities then
I found an anger management course on
the internet it was nerve-wracking at
first and I knew I'd have to face up to
the aspects of my life I'd prefer to
overlook yet the course was a turning
point and by the time it had finished I
felt confident I could control myself
then 2 years later I hit my husband
again I had become complacent assumed
that IID changed when I slapped his face
for the last time I was forced to
confront the situation this time I told
my family and my friends what had been
happening that they didn't critic ize or
judge was a huge help soon after I
decided to go part-time as a lawyer and
a mediator I now run a course on how to
help people deal with anger and conflict
my husband and I are still together I'm
careful not to choose language that is
aggressive if I ever feel angry and feel
my heart beat Quicken I leave the room
but that is rare I wouldn't claim our
marriage is now perfect but it's pretty
good A caring and gentle relationship
which feels like an achievement for me
what if we looked at male abuse like
that you know she talked about how this
was a terrible thing that she wanted
wanted to overcome and yet she's still
married and you know I I think this
story is important because a lot of
people will say that women are not
violent a lot of people will say that
women are not abusive but in my
experience women are more abusive than
men they are more violent than men and
often times when it comes to abusive
relationships they are much more likely
to hit the husband than the husband is
to hit the wife this is not uncommon
I've heard stories like this so many
times and the issue is really we tell
women that being crazy is a good thing
oh we even have phrases like I went
crazy how is going crazy socially
acceptable in society it's not it should
not be and when these stories like that
it kind of begs the question if this is
one woman that this has happened to how
many women are there that are abusing
their husbands and their husbands are
just sticking it out because they love
their wives men are much more likely to
work through conflict than women are
women throw in the towel men tend to try
to work it out but guys th this stuff is
more common in society than really I
think women admit to and I really do
think as women we are more violent I
will die on this hill but let me know
what you guys think in the comments make
sure you like the video on your way out
get yourself a women shouldn't vote
t-shirt from the audacity network. store
and I will talk to you next time